[Music]
morning guys Viva Las Vegas we're going
to Vegas the van that you rented there's
Anna Cristina and Steven the cure in
there and then Gina's vlogging over
there and open touch me yeah I put a
tripod tiny camera in this job we're at
the old office this is the meeting spot
for us to go we're gonna go pick up
Barton geo and then we're going to fake
God I'm gonna try I'm gonna drive really
chill just gonna drive down the track -
why do you what do you make that
announcement Joe because I usually drive
aggressive yes so it's a very known
thing in our group that whenever Joe
drives you got to prepare for thickness
for you to get nauseous because he ends
up driving we're checking out Barton
Joe's new
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're all getting out of the van finally
here check out the ceiling though looks
so cool we're staying at the MGM and
we're gonna have a magnificent great
magical time and all right we finally
made it to our room you got a nice
king-sized bed
and we got a nice little living room
sort of it's pretty cool this is a nice
room I like it it took us like a whole
hour so you're from my peripheral do the
things that you did for my peripheral I
saw that that's funny cuz he was like
I'll posing ready for me to turn the
camera and then I'm just still talking
to you guys in the end it was pretty
funny anyway it took like a freaking
hour to get our rooms cuz joe booked
everyone a room visit a company vacation
and it just took forever and then also I
forgot to mention but on the way here it
took us the whole six hours to get here
but there was this accident and what are
you doing just look up you been I can't
really good I'm on your leg oh yeah in
the car right well if you haven't
noticed already everyone here is
vlogging so you guys will be able to see
this same trip through many different
perspectives all of our friends channels
you can go check those out right before
we cross the state line we were just
trying to get all our bad juju out since
we're planning on gambling and just
having a good time right so we're just
like cursing at each other were like FBO
and we're like okay cool we got it out
and then we cross the state line we're
like okay nice now we have all the good
energy ready to go and we're gonna be
having a great time during this weekend
it's actually Easter weekend which I
didn't realize but we're not spending
Easter with Isaac we're gonna be what's
dead
but we get to spend it with everybody
else Oh grown-up time yeah time you just
mean it's not really cheese like fleas
easily yeah oh my god we were hanging
out with our girls I know I know what
you're eating kids I know it's awful Las
Vegas for nothing everybody's in Las
Vegas
yeah like drinking and gambling yeah
exactly yeah what were you guys thinking
we made it to the Luxor and we are
trying to get to the bodies exhibit
really quickly because it's only like a
time to window that we could see this
exhibit we're cutting it really really
really close so
are rushing to get there hopefully they
let us in and we got to see some bodies
it's like a strip club no these are like
dead bodies just oh it's completely
different kind of money okay I just
finished going through the whole exhibit
the bodies and man I feel so weird
because I think knowing that those are
real people like just made me just feel
so disturbed like the entire time I'm
like this is like not even like this
isn't even like nah and I'm like that
experience and now we have to go eat and
I'm like I feel queasy but I'm so hungry
but it's like this is weird like it was
just I don't know man I'm just kind of
like I lost for words I don't think I'd
ever do that again so right now we're
Jake
[Music]
the crew because we're rolling deep our
daily jalena
look at this yummers with my favorite
the heat on the rim playing craps and
this is the first time that we I've ever
been up this much we've literally
tripled our money that we started with
it was such a freaking fun we're so rich
we're not rich we're not return off as I
started with a little bit of money but
it was really awesome because our entire
group of friends took up the entire
table of crap so with such good energy
it was amazing I loved it this is pretty
fun this has been a really great first
night because we are all we're just
beautiful when you're gambling we also
drink a lot if you haven't noticed KC's
actually really drunk right now
[Music]
we're gonna go get in the morning things
to do in the morning everything we could
choose the tax right anyway look at the
view it's so pretty
whoa there's a homeless dude down there
she's having a great time these girls
are on their phones there's a sexually
Casey laughing like a dolphin
everything is just okay with the world I
love it this is a great night everyone
else is logging and storing we're
heading to our hotel is it open I don't
know let's go see I love that idea Nikki
right good morning
it is the very next day now I woke up so
swollen and with a sore throat because
the air here is so dry now everyone in
the group chat we're like oh no I hope
we're not catching Bart in Gio's
sickness because Gio got really sick
yesterday and she stayed in so she could
feel better and then Bart woke up this
morning feeling sick so like oh no that
sucks but then wait we also have sore
throats and then ya hear that voice that
sounds scary it sounds like a monster
yeah my face feels so swollen my hands
feel swollen too like this is all that
sodium cuz I very unhealthy yesterday it
was like pizza was the very last thing
we ate but then before that I had a
chili cheese dog hot dogs so was very
bad anyway right now we're gonna go try
to grab something really quick to eat
and then we book some massages and we're
gonna spend some time at the spa with
Martin Jo so hopefully they feel better
and hopefully we don't catch whatever
they have see because we always don't
want to spend time with each other but
you know hopefully we don't get sick but
yeah rjk vacation is going swell alright
so we just had our massages it was so
good I honestly feel like this massage
was my number one most favorite massage
I've ever done in my life because my
masseuse her hands were so soft the
pressure was consistent and she had like
some sort of condition where she kind of
like shapes a little bit so I felt like
a vibrating massage it was so good hi I
just I wish I could just bring her home
with me I'm like oh can I steal you away
but anyway so foreign Gio
like I said are very sick so we came to
this place to I be like ooh veneering
vitamins stuff so they could try to feel
better and I accidentally drank out of
Gio's water bottle without realizing it
so I'm really scared that I'm also
getting a beginning stick so and then
plus I feel really dehydrated from last
night's drinking so I'm gonna also join
them and then Gina ambos are here too
Kasey decided to opt out and beautifly
be a party pooper even though he doesn't
feel good you could probably benefit
from some hydration she did
it's not that bad but he's just being
frugal even though we won like yesterday
like come on we have we could we just
lurch a little bit it was juice Briggs
massages were really expensive motel
massages in Vegas are crazy but anyway
we're treating herself we're on vacation
it's okay we're starving after we did
the IV drip thing I felt significantly
more hydrated and I'm ready to eat
buffet time of course I like you
strategy tell me your strategy it's also
more expensive than anything else get
that at first and go after the red meats
after episode seafood veggies also more
expensive and
I'm so hungry then you salad this part I
like your strategy deep food first and
then look who we ran into
it's Dante what to do
we are about to watch
but look there's an elk
[Music]
all right so we watched oh it was
amazing it was crazy like how the then
it was I can't even talk I haven't I
actually haven't drink drank drank drunk
what the heck man I'm set I sound like
oh my god I can't talk I haven't drink I
for some reason can't form words with my
mouth my mouth isn't listening to my
brain when it wants to speak I don't
know I sound really crazy anyway the
point is Oh was really cool but halfway
through it because like waters involved
in this in this show so I can eat it a
piece so bad I was like oh my god
everything is like water and they're
slashing and they're doing all this I
need a P so finally we were able to find
a restroom after the show and then I was
at the Bellagio we're staying at the MGM
so we drove over here and then we
decided to like some of the girls we
decided to change our world pretty I
have a seat my mouth can't work right
now out of what we were wearing
previously like that all this so weak so
you can be comfortable anyway I was just
gonna show you my outfit change see that
in the mirror yeah this romper that I'm
wearing right now I wore it for my
bachelorette party every time I wear
this I always think of that night and
then I'm wearing some sandals I'm
keeping my leather jacket on cuz it's
cold in the casinos what are you doing
you look very comfortable do you know
what the most dangerous thing about
coming back to the room is how you get
tired yes it's your fault you sat down
let's go that's this couch is so funky
yes are you drink
no I only drank one like little very
water now again tonic
from earlier but let's get it on now I
know my fear so swollen look they don't
even fit in my sandals
you're like spilling out on the edge
honestly then I totally regret eating
the nasty stuff that I ate yesterday
because I woke up today so swollen like
too much sodium I didn't like it I don't
like it my eyes my eyelids were stolen
earlier today combination of the sodium
that I'm not used to and the alcohol
that you're not used to true cuz I don't
usually drink I just drink when I'm
around friends vacation but anyway we're
gonna go meet up with everyone and go
play some more crap because we want to
win some more money
all right so it's day three is it day 3
day 3 Vegas I turn the block today and
you know it's gonna be a lot of food I
got a little bit of a Mexican breakfast
to start my day with some of the most uh
and the reason why I'm vlogging today
though it's because TIFF is busy right
now
having a top-secret meeting over some
new project that she's doing with the JK
girls which I don't even know what
they've actually announced it yet so I'm
gonna keep it pretty vague here at the
top-secret project I'm actually spying
on them a little bit because you're way
over there haven't there maybe you see
his blue hair in the back of her head
how was your meeting it was a meeting
amazing oh your time to make a baby I
don't know yeah you're just as big as I
am if not more big as I was telling them
it's not secret
so like I'm gonna be very vague with
this so I'm sorry I was thinking oh
maybe maybe after the meeting you get
you can shed a little bit more light on
it but I guess not all right good
morning I just took a really long nap
and I'm still trying to wake up everyone
is going super fast with everything
right now because they're not trying to
wake up and I
then I managed to get dressed though hey
and we got on our way to the Rio to do
dinner and head and tell her yes
watch antenna teller get to see some
magic comedy magic so is your day it's
been great we went to the pool with a
girl like the girls were just driving
the lazy river and connecting and
bonding I like to stay cool
[Music]
all you can drink I want to be part of
the party what they're showing so it's
pretty cool we got a photo with teller
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]